you and mike have done some some things
together
um yeah so how i met mike
you know in other words
oh yeah oh yeah oh get there so mike
mike was talking about this toad and i'm
like i don't even know you know the
first time he brought the the
the person here was a big deal he was
like oh columbus you're a [ __ ] you're
scared to do it i was like no i just
don't know what the hell
i was like no that's just like me i
think i don't know what i don't know
what it is you know what i mean and then
um
and then one day i was like all right
and so me and my wife did it in separate
rooms and you know we had two completely
different experiences for me
it's like i literally was like for
however long in in the cosmos like one
with the cosmos and i you know it was
scary because i was seeing dealing with
a lot but coming out of it and the
residual effects lasted for like a month
yeah it does last it was crazy so it was
like but it changed like it changed my
perspective it changed my mood it
changed my energy it changed my
frequency
um
i don't know i don't know how mike could
do it all the time once a year i was
like how many times i don't know how
often you do it what would you mean by
frequency
i used to vibrate on such a high
frequency meaning like
my anxiety because i have anxiety i
didn't realize how how high my frequency
was in vibrating so if i get around
other people and my frequency starts to
vibrate i move the energy
i know i do right
and even in my own home if i come in
with some messed up energy then i change
the frequency of my house right yeah so
i just figured out a way to kind of like
keep my frequency
after that it's like
where are the controllers of our our
our frequencies right and you know my i
figured out how to level out my
frequency after the toe i've done the
toe with mike too but did you did you
fully let go
you've done it once or how many times
have you done it once
[Music]
i mean i think i'm at a point now it was
two years ago so i think i could do it
again now but
you know uh it's never too many times
for me i just oh i like that feeling but
from the first time that you did it to
now you have completely different
experiences right
yeah
so what are your experiences now
it's all positive
yeah
it's positive everybody's one with me
everybody loves me i love them and
there's no problem so are you walking
around in the room are you just laying
there the whole time um i'm on the floor
and um
nothing exists
time doesn't exist matters doesn't exist
yeah but uh it's a
noticeable acceptance from a divine
power oh that's the bar a noticeable
acceptance from a divine power yes
that sums it up yeah man what did you
feel that did did um and
the the emotions of love and hate and
everything in between and how everything
is beautiful
you know what i'm saying you walk into
this
this this uh this dream that shares your
whole life story like within seconds you
know what i'm saying you're like oh for
real that's exactly you start feeling
compassion for people and for you know
forgiveness freakiness of yourself that
was big i think that's another thing
that was another one forgiveness you
know like i was angry i was angry for a
lot of things feeling mistreated feeling
you know uh
uh used or you know lied on or whatever
i had any i had anger issues and like
angry with my mom you know for killing
my dad old stuff all of that stuff yeah
started to let go of you know what i
mean
after the toe